good afternoon
[Applause]
how's everybody doing out there
welcome
so I hope you're having a fantastic time
NDC London 2023 day one for the next
hour I am gonna tell you
stories about electricity
now uh
I have kind of a nice I don't really
have a job I just do cool things and
sometimes I get paid for it and uh a a
big European Company the company who
builds the Control software for most of
the power grids in the European Union
got in touch with him last year and said
we're doing a developer conference can
you do a keynote for us and I was like
yeah what do you want it to be about and
they said can you do a talk about
electricity and I'm like you're the
experts
like you're supposed to know all the
electricity stuff they're like yeah but
really we don't really do electricity we
do software I was like well if you're
doing software you have to like do you
have any analog software that runs on
steam power and they're like you know
what we mean so I got the chance to you
know geek out and dig into all of these
uh cool and weird details about
electricity and all the different ways
that technology software we apply
electrical power in different ways and
so that's kind of where this talk came
from and I put it on the the pitch for
NDC London and I put a talk next to it
which was a technical talk about how to
write JavaScript and the rest of the
committee went we don't want to listen
to you talking about JavaScript do the
thing with the lightning in it and so
this is sockets Sparks and Magic Smoke
and uh this is
this is me uh I'm not on Twitter well I
am on Twitter anymore but I do all my
fun chat now on hackyderm.io because
I've joined the Freddy verse uh the
future of the web is decentralized but
it has nothing to do with cryptocurrency
it's about running lots of little
twitters that aren't birds that are
elephants and they're all chatting to
one another and uh you know the older
thing about who would win in a fight
between one elephant-sized bird and a
thousand bird-sized elephants
I'm betting on the elephants I run
versatile I'm a Microsoft MVP I run the
london.net user group when we don't have
to cancel it because of train strikes
and venues pulling out on us and I once
invented a programming language just for
all you folks out there who really want
to apply for those rockstar programmer
jobs that they still advertise once in a
while on LinkedIn and we
are going to talk about electricity
because without electricity we wouldn't
have any software we wouldn't have any
hardware we wouldn't have any uh Mobile
Cellular networks we wouldn't have any
internet any YouTube any uh dotnet and
Lambda and cloud and serverless and all
this kind of stuff
and so we are going to work our way up
the scale of electrical power and we are
actually going to start here we are
going to start at zero because it turns
out you can do Computing without using
any electricity there is a um so there's
a bit of controversy about whether
prehistoric or you know ancient
civilizations had electricity or not uh
there is an archaeological find it's a
thing called The Babylon battery which a
bunch of people found and they went this
is really exciting look it's got an
outer chamber and it's got copper and if
you put paper in here then it becomes a
battery and they could use it to
electroplate things in ancient Persia
and everyone went have we found any
electroplated things from ancient Persia
and well no but and they're like it's
probably not a battery so we don't think
that there was uh you know ancient
civilizations had batteries but they did
have Computing devices
this is a fragment of a thing called the
anticherthera mechanism it was found in
a shipwreck of the island of antacothera
which is a in the Mediterranean off the
coast of Greece
and it basically came up as a corroded
lump of metal that a bunch of
archaeologists kind of started looking
at they x-rayed it and they discovered
that inside this thing were mechanical
gears and cogs and things this was a
computer this was an ancient Greek
computer that was used to calculate the
phases of the Moon it had little gears
in it that would tell you when the next
solar eclipse was likely to be and the
prevailing theory is that they used this
to predict when it was time to have the
Olympics so this is hundreds probably
thousands of years before the Advent of
electricity now
this idea of mechanical computers
computers that don't use electrical
signaling uh kind of came to a peak with
a guy called Charles Babbage this is a
uh so Babbage designed mechanical
Computing systems this is a photograph
of a reproduction of part of a system he
designed called the analytical engine
now he designed computers that were
never built during his lifetime he died
in about 1840 I think and during his
lifetime one he didn't have the money to
fund the construction of his designs to
the engineering Precision did not exist
to actually allow them to realize it
this was a project that came out of the
science museum in London in the 1990s
and they built a working replica of a
simpler system a thing called The
Difference Engine for calculating
logarithms he designed a general purpose
computer called the analytical engine
which would run programs punched on the
cards that were used to run mechanical
looms and uh this thing at the moment a
team at the science museum is digitizing
all of his notes to see if they can get
a blueprint to see if maybe they will be
able to build a working replica of his
analytical engine so uh give it another
10 maybe 15 years there might be a
general purpose Turing complete
mechanical computer ticking around in a
university or in a museum somewhere in
the world but mechanical Computing
actually went on a lot longer than any
of us think this is a thing called the
northern bomb site it's a mechanical
bomb site used for dropping bombs it was
used as event of the 1930s and it was
used by European and American Air Forces
right up until the end of a cold war the
sort of 1980s early 1990s the Russian or
the Soviet and later the Russian Space
Program they were using mechanical
gyroscopes to navigate space capsules
until
2002. now at the moment there's not a
huge amount going on to do with
mechanical computers but uh
we have a Rover on Mars human beings
have uh click click click click click
come on come on clicker you can do it
there we go
um
so Mars as far as we know has no organic
life
which means there is a planet in the
solar system that is populated entirely
by robots which is kind of cool
and uh there are I think seven probes
have been sent and have been roaming
around on the surface of Mars some of
them are still going they didn't put a
helicopter up there last year and NASA
would love to do the same thing and land
a probe on the surface of Venus
there is a problem
the atmosphere on Venus is a mixture of
carbon dioxide and sulfuric acid the
temperature on the surface of Venus is
460 degrees Celsius uh we got any scuba
divers in the room any of you have done
scuba on holiday yeah the pressure at
the surface of Venus is equivalent to
scuba diving a depth of one kilometer
surface pressure is 90 bar now do any of
you fancy building an electrical circuit
that is going to survive at 90
atmospheres of pressure where the
atmosphere is 460 degrees sulfuric acid
we have landed things on the surface of
Venus and you know what happened to them
they dissolved and they melted we cannot
build any kind of electrical circuit
that is going to function reliably in
those conditions but there is a team at
the jet propulsion laboratory at Nasa
who are like all right can't use
electricity can't use radio can't use
Transmissions
we're going to do this
prototype for a wind-powered autonomous
Rover the thing in the middle this thing
is about this high it's about a meter
and a half high this artist's impression
of the design they're working on I think
in the middle is a giant wind turbine
now they have no control over this thing
they're going to drop it on the surface
of Venus if this project goes ahead
um and as the wind blows it's just gonna
roam around the place and poke stuff and
measure wind speed and measure
temperature and if you look closely at
this picture the thing on the top that
looks like four CDs those are Optical
semaphore plates that are reflective to
radar so there's a satellite in orbit
around Venus and when this thing kind of
gets onto a bit of soft ground one of
the gears is going to move one of those
slightly and it'll reflect a particular
radar pattern and the orbiting satellite
can go all right we have no control over
it but we know where it is we know which
way it's moving we know how fast the
wind is blowing we know what the soil
conditions are like down there we know
the temperature all the stuff using
completely mechanical circuits and
Mechanical Devices what you have to
admit is the most badass steampunk thing
you have ever heard of
but they're still working on that so
let's get back to the idea of
electricity now electricity is useful
because of three things that we human
beings can do with it one of them is the
reason why this guy is famous and for a
long time appeared on the the old
British 20 pound note that was in
circulation for about 20 years
we can turn electricity into movement
and we can turn movement back into
electricity the guy on the banknote is
Michael Faraday who discovered
electromagnetism now this is how one
most electrical power generation works
we have spinning turbines we put
movement in from steam or burning coal
or water or any number of things we're
going to talk about we get electricity
out the other side too we can put
electricity in the back we get motion we
get Motors we also this is the most
significant Discovery in the history of
humankind because it is also how heavy
metal works because the pickup in an
electric guitar that thing in the middle
of the picture that's a couple of
thousand turns a copper wire and when
you pluck the string on an electric
guitar the steel string moves through a
magnetic field and it induces a current
in those coils that we feed into an
amplifier and heavy metal comes out the
other side really really important
engineering principle
the second thing that we can do with
electricity is we can turn it into
radiation and we can turn radiation back
into electricity and uh it turns out
there is really only one flavor of
radiation or one kind of radiation just
comes in different intensities different
wavelengths way down at the bottom of
the spectrum here we have gamma rays
these are very very bad for you unless
you're in a Marvel comic book in real
life no you don't end up as a superhero
or your teeth in your hair for that and
then you die then we get up a little
higher you have a fall off your bike
you've fallen over skiing you're going
for an x-ray
radiation put electricity in the metal
radiation comes out they use it to take
a picture yep there you go you fell over
and you broke your leg we get into the
ultraviolet part of the spectrum the
awesome day glow effects you get on
nightclubs and bad water slides we have
the visible spectrum blue orange yellow
yellow red all of the colors that our
eyes can see top end of that we have
infrared which is where it starts
turning into heat just above that we
have Wi-Fi the 2.4 gigahertz band we
also have microwave ovens in the 2.4
gigahertz band uh have any of you ever
lived in a shared house where the
microwave was next to the Wi-Fi point
and every time someone goes to heat
their pasta or your YouTube stop working
yeah that's why exactly the same
radiation in the same spectrum and Wi-Fi
2.4 G microwave radiation same part of
the spectrum we get up a little higher
and we get into Radio AM FM long wave
medium wave and radio is the second most
important invention in the history of
humankind because it means that you can
have heavy metal without having to be in
the same room as the people who are
making the heavy metal which was a big
big innovation and the third thing we
can do with electricity is we can store
it now you go to a store you buy a
Duracell battery you put it in your
camera you put it in your PowerPoint
clicker like this one or the remote
control for your TV it works once right
and it works for a little while and then
eventually it stops working and you
recycle it responsibly or you throw it
in the trash now
it's probably occurred to some of you
hey what if I put the electricity can I
put the electricity back in the battery
these kind of batteries you can't they
don't like that because what's going on
inside one of these batteries when you
buy it is you have what's called a
cathode this is made of magnesium
dioxide there is an anode which is a
little needle made of zinc running down
the middle of this thing and there is an
electrolyte potassium hydroxide who
knows what battery tastes like
you ever had the thing where you've got
a piece of electrical the battery has
burst or it's leaked and you're trying
to fix it and you've got to strip the
wire with your teeth and you're like
yeah that is potassium hydroxide that
horrible sour kind of burning taste and
when you buy a battery from the store
what is going on with it is this a
collector in the middle this is the the
brass pin that actually gets the current
out this thing is in a steel casing and
it is absolutely full of atoms and the
atoms move from the cathode and when you
start a circuit flowing all those atoms
go hey
let's go over there look at that that
looks awesome and they start to move and
when they move they generate a tiny tiny
tiny tiny tiny amount of electricity but
there are lots of them a couple of
hundred million billion billion billion
of these atoms and every time one of
them moves it generates current which
flows through once all the atoms have
relocated that's it batteries finished
no more electricity recycle it now this
is one kind of electrochemical reaction
this one is not reversible if you pump
power back into a Duracell battery it'll
get hot it'll expand and it might even
explode if you're very lucky but it's
not the only electrochemical reaction
the lead acid battery in your car that
one doesn't care that's lead lead oxide
with sulfuric acid between the two you
pump the power back into it it just
switches it so the lead becomes the lead
oxide and the lead oxide turns back to
lead and the oxides basically just kind
of slosh backwards and forwards that's
how car batteries get recharged now
Battery Technology has the advances in
Battery tech within my lifetime are
absolutely unbelievable when I was a kid
electric vehicles were some of you
probably recognize this it's milk float
top speed 20 kilometers an hour maximum
range 100ks that's about what 70 miles
and after it had finished delivering all
the milk to your neighbors it had to go
back to the depot to recharge for 16
hours before it was ready to go out
tomorrow and deliver a little bit more
milk today
we have electric cars that can do
hundreds of kilometers on half an hour
of charge top speed of about 180 k's now
we can do some astonishing things with
batteries and energy storage the state
of the art on this has evolved massively
could we store enough electricity to
power a city
we're going to come back to that later
but we are going to talk now we looked
at three capabilities of electricity we
can use it to create motion we can use
it to create radiation and we can store
it now
I'm talking to you right now my uh voice
is creating pressure waves in the air
this little microphone here is picking
them up and amplifying them pressure is
reaching your eardrums and when it does
your eardrum is turning the signal from
my voice the pressure from my voice into
a tiny tiny electrical current that is
getting sent up to your brain now the
human nervous system works on about 10
millivolts of electricity and it doesn't
work like a conventional wire the cells
in your nervous system it's more like a
Mexican wave a little cell in your ear
goes oh I heard a noise electricity it
charges the cell membrane and the one
next to it goes oh charge I'm going to
charge my cell membrane and this
propagates through your body into your
brain where something goes hey that
guy's talking about electricity and we
come full circle now
one of the first people to do extensive
study into the way electricity works in
biological systems was uh this guy Luigi
galvani now you probably heard the
expression galvanized it's a way of
coating things with zinc to stop them
rusting and uh this is a little bit icky
but what galvani did one of his
experiments is uh he took dissected
animals and he applied electricity to uh
front legs as the famous example and
they twitched and he came up with this
conclusion that the thing that was
making the muscles move was an
electrical signal this was the basis of
a physioelectromagnetism now one of the
first people who read a pre-print of his
paper was Mary Shelley this was about
three years before she wrote
Frankenstein in which the Dr
Frankenstein and his nameless monster
um he puts together a monster out of you
know bits of cadavers and stuff and then
uses the power of lightning to reanimate
it so biological systems do weird cool
things with electricity I did actually
break my leg skiing a couple of years
ago and uh I got one of these I got an
electroshock therapy thing to help kind
of rebuild the muscle after I had that
my leg glued back together and this was
really strange you kind of put these
electrodes on your leg like this you sit
and watch TV and after half an hour one
of your legs is really tired because
it's just been the muscles in it are
going twitch twitch every time you get
this little electric shock in it now uh
one of the most interesting applications
of electrophysiology is this
it's pacemaker
some people's hearts don't beat
regularly and some people's hearts do
beat regularly but they don't beat fast
enough to give enough oxygen to all the
parts of that person's body and so we
have come up with a way of running you
look closely you can see these two wires
actually running into the heart and all
they are doing is they're using a tiny
electrical signal to regulate the
beating of a human heart now the battery
in a pacemaker has about as much
capacity as the battery in your phone
battery in your phone has enough power
to watch YouTube videos and send
WhatsApp messages for 10 hours or to
keep a human heart beating for 10 years
which is probably just as well because
replacing the battery in these things
one they got to cut you open and two and
they take the battery out your heart
stops beating until they put the new one
in so this isn't the Genius Bar kind of
can you put a new battery in this thing
it's a fairly substantial procedure
so uh we can do cool things with
biological systems using very very tiny
amounts of electricity but we've also
done cool things with artificial systems
and mechanisms
this is Voyage one
Voyage one was uh launched in the 1970s
and at the moment it is uh still
operational launched in 1977 left the
solar system in 2012 August 2012. it is
still out there and it is still
transmitting now on board Voyager 1 and
Voyager 2 is a thing called a
radiothermal isotope generator
radioisotype thermal generator
um chunk of plutonium
connected to a thermocouple which is a
thing that turns heat into electricity
that's how this thing works there are
three of these on board they give out
about 400 or they used to give out about
400 watts of power when they were new
these two spacecraft have been flying
through space for longer than I have
been alive and they are slowly beginning
to shut down because the half-life of
the plutonium means it's not quite as
warm as it used to be so it's not
putting out quite as much power as it
used to which means that NASA are slowly
shutting down various systems on board
Voyager now
some of you may have seen this picture
it's called the pale blue dot it was
taken by Voyager 1 in the 1990s from
outside the orbit of Saturn this is us
that is planet Earth hanging in the
darkness this is probably the most
expensive selfie ever taken right
but Voyager was built in the 1970s
we didn't have iPhone cameras in the
1970s we didn't have charge couple
devices webcams CMOS all the stuff we
take for granted today
Voyager took this Photograph using a
thing called a vidicon tube and stored
the picture on tape
there is a tape deck in space right now
two of them in fact which was specially
built for this it's magnetic type now
the two reels here they had to go in
opposite directions because if they went
in the same direction it would mess with
the gyroscopes and Voyager would have
gone off course Voyager 1 has been shut
down the tapes on it are no longer
working Voyager 1 is just pinging back
an occasional hey I'm still awake at
here message the tape deck on Voyager 2
is still working
and we know this because NASA publishes
the space flight operations schedule for
Voyager on their website every couple of
weeks as a PDF and this is the operation
schedule for right now January 2023.
this is Saturday January 21st which is
four days ago and there you go that's
the playback instruction the 1970s tape
deck that is flying through outer space
beyond the reaches of the solar system
on Saturday they sent a message going
hey back it up replay the tape let's see
what we got they don't have much there
is not very much out there for Voyager
to be taking pictures of but this 1970s
Tech is still out there it's still
working and the reason we can pick it up
if you look at Voyager
the main feature you'll notice is this
thing it's the main radio antenna dish
on the back and it's a bad three and a
half four meters across you can see a
picture of it there with one of the
engineers who worked on it now
Voyage is 23 billion kilometers away
from Earth it takes 21 hours for those
radio signals to reach us the total
transmitting power of that transmitter
there is 23 Watts it's about as bright
as the light bulb in your refrigerator
and we can pick it up from the other
side of the solar system because we have
this NASA's deep space Network it's a
three radio telescopes it's one in
California there's one in Spain and the
other one is parks in Australia now
there's I don't know did you see Tom
Scott did a video about Parks last week
and one of the things he said in that
video one of the things that the person
he told me said in that video if you
take a feather and you drop a feather
onto a carpeted floor the noise of that
feather landing on the carpet puts out
more energy than all the signals we have
ever received from all the radio
transmitter the radio telescopes that we
have ever built if you took your cell
phone and dropped it on the moon that
would be the brightest thing in the sky
to one of these telescopes they are
unbelievably sensitive so we are still
picking up signals from Voyager it's out
there it's getting weaker eventually
probably within the next couple of years
it's going to shut down but
you come across the idea of a light year
right like if light flies into space in
a straight line for one year that
distance is one light year humankind is
nowhere close to being able to send
anything a light year or we we are we
just only just got started you know but
if Voyager makes it to November 2026 it
will cross the one light day threshold
it will be more than 24 hours signal
away from Earth I think that's a pretty
cool Milestone and when it happens if it
happens if it survives that long we will
find out about it through the medium of
electricity because it will pop up on a
mobile phone or on a news feed or on a
website or somewhere and now we are into
the uh the bit of the electrical kind of
voltage range which I call the
user-friendly electricity the the handy
stuff that comes out of the wall
um now did you know you can actually
tell quite a lot about a country by the
shape of their plug sockets like you
know their attitude how well adjusted
they are like these are the plug sockets
they use in Denmark and these are the
plug sockets they use in the United
States and uh
and I put this on Twitter and someone
said oh that's not even the best one in
a in hospitals in Denmark they have ones
that wink at you
now
plug sockets are different shapes you
travel around the world there's a lot of
people in this room do I know and you're
constantly looking out for adapters and
how do I plug my laptop into this wall
and a lot of the devices we use now they
can cope with a range of different
voltages they can't necessarily cope
with a range of different shapes uh so
it's okay you can always improvise you
know
um don't do this or you will probably
die
but it's not just the shape of the plug
socket that's important we also have
different voltage standards the UK the
European Union quite a lot of the
basically the bits of the world that
were fairly recently invaded by the
British tend to use around 220 volts
North America uses 110 and actually
North America uses 110 because they got
there first because they rolled out
electric lighting early enough that they
hadn't standardized on a 220 volt system
yet so they were the early pioneers and
now they're stuck with that
um but uh
there was a wonderful theory about the
way electric devices work microchips
transistors these kinds of things which
is that they are full of Magic Smoke and
when they make them in the factory they
take the smoke and they trap the smoke
inside the Chip And they seal it up and
if the chip gets too hot what happens is
it cracks and the Magic Smoke comes out
and after that it doesn't work anymore
now many many years ago my first
first-hand experience of Magic Smoke was
a computer that looked like this AMD k6
it had a I think a four gig hard drive
and 64 Megs of RAM and Windows 95 and uh
it was that point in my life where I had
enough money for one computer that I
couldn't possibly afford another one and
I was constantly tinkering and poking
around this thing and one day I was I
was poking around the back putting in a
sound card or something and I
accidentally bumped this switch
from 220 to 1 15 I didn't notice and I
plugged it in and I put 220 volts
through a power supply that was
expecting 115 there was a lot of Magic
Smoke and a very big bang and after that
the computer didn't work anymore until I
I wombled a new power supply from
somewhere now
some devices
we give them too much voltage they
explode and they don't work anymore
after that
sometimes though putting too much
voltage through something is actually a
good idea
if you go into your computer's bios
there will be a little setting in there
somewhere which allows you to control
how fast it's gonna go and raw clock
speed who is in Richard Campbell's talk
this morning he's talking about Moore's
Law and he's talking about the numbers
of transistors we can put on chips and
stuff and one of the measurements of
computing power is just raw clock speed
how many times per second can your
computer do a single calculation and we
routinely have you know 2 600 so 2.6
gigahertz that 2.6 million operations
per second that sounds like a lot of
instructions right
now let's say we want to sit down and we
want to play straight now if you're
running stray on a kind of 4k monitor
you're talking about sort of you know 4
000 by 12 or 1200 pixels it's got about
probably about a million pixels on the
screen about a 240 000 or so and you
want to run that at 60 frames per second
which means each pixel on your screen is
going to be lucky if it gets I think we
get a bit to a point there's about 17
000 operations per second per pixel we
need to do that 60 times and then you
take into account well you've got to do
a lot of vector and Matrix arithmetic to
draw a game like this you've got to
calculate lighting effects you've got to
calculate fog and distance and also in
the background the computer is also
checking your email and it's running the
audio and it's running the network stack
and it's probably doing something stupid
with Microsoft teams in the background
suddenly 2.6 billion jillion million
operations per second doesn't look like
very much
and so the question comes up can we make
them go faster now
a couple of years ago
um I built a gaming PC for my brother we
wumbled some bits and we bought a power
supply and a hard drive we ordered a lot
of parts from eBay to put this thing
together on the cheap we put it all
together he came down to my place for
the weekend we split it all together we
set it all up ran a burning test 24
hours Rock Solid everything's fine he
took it home
Rings me a couple of hours later it's
crashed
I gotta visit him in Bristol where he's
living at the time switch it on it
crashes we switch it on it crashes like
all right I'll take it home and look at
it I take it home
take it apart little bits run another
burning test absolutely Rock Solid
he takes it back crashes
I'm like
why does it only crash in Bristol so I
go up and I stay for the weekend we take
it apart I take the tools and everything
we take the thing apart we run a burning
test absolutely Rock Solid put it back
together put it under the desk it
crashes straight away I'm thinking what
this is the weirdest thing that I've
ever met from across it just keeps doing
this by the way keep yourself on your
toes put a blue screen of death and all
your PowerPoint presentations so when it
comes up you don't know if it's a real
one
eventually we caught it we figured out
what had happened because we caught a uh
just before it crashed really really
hard we got a thermal overload warning
now the motherboard we bought on eBay
was old and it was a little bit worn out
and it had a great big huge heavy
heatsink on it and whenever we had been
running Diagnostics we had the computer
up on a desk on its side with the
motherboard flat and the heatsink
vertically sat on it soon as we thought
it was good case back on put it on its
side under the desk and the heatsink was
pulling away from the CPU by about a
millimeter and that was enough
that was enough that within five minutes
the CPU got to 98 degrees Celsius and
just went I'm not playing anymore now
cooling is a massive problem we want to
put More Voltage into CPUs because More
Voltage makes them go faster and we want
faster we like faster but More Voltage
also means more heat modern Intel CPU
um just sitting doing not very much is
ticking over at about 60 65 Watts this
is like an old-fashioned incandescent
light bulb sealed in a metal box and you
need to keep that cool otherwise you're
going to have a problem you start
encoding video you cramp crank up a game
it's going to start pulling 150 200
Watts that's like three incandescent
light bulbs in a little metal box and
you need to keep that thing cool first
computer I ever had didn't have a
heatsink by the time mid-90s came around
I had a 486 with this kind of little
Metal Hedgehog on the top then we got
the big metal Hedgehog with the fan for
a hat and then we got the giant enormous
Metal Hedgehog with the huge exhaust fan
on the back like a vacuum cleaner now
the world record for raw CPU clock speed
was not achieved
with a supercomputer or a one-of-kind
prototype or anything particularly fancy
there's people with one of these it's an
AMD FX processor you can buy this on
Amazon right now for about 120 quid and
in 2014
somebody calling themselves the stilt
submitted this verified screenshot to
the cpu-z validator site 8000
8722 megahertz a 8.7 gigs
they took that uh you can see a couple
of the details on there so they took an
off-the-shelf CPU they cranked the
voltage up to about 2.1 2.2 volts
overclocked the hell out of it and put
the whole computer in a bath of liquid
nitrogen
that's how they got it stable at the
speed now that's a little extreme like
you know liquid nitrogen is not really
stuff you want to be messing around with
terribly much we have this thing Richard
was talking about this morning Moore's
Law
now Mo's law for a long time was
computers get faster double in speed
every 18 months but what Gordon Moore
actually said is the number of
transistors we can put on a single piece
of silicon is going to double every 18
months now for a long time that
correlated exactly with clock speed
because more transistors meant it went
twice as fast we are getting to a point
now where we are hitting the buffers at
the end of physics and we cannot push
them any further
mechanical hard drives state-of-the-art
staple for years and years and years we
got incredibly good at building these
things you know and these use little
tiny magnetic particles you've got a
disk that's spinning at 15 000
revolutions per minute and you've got a
head on the end of it that's watching
this disc coming around and going that
bit there three two one grab it as it
goes past and see if it was a one or a
zero and then off we go again and you
know for a long time this was the state
of the art in storage these things are
fantastic unless you drop them or bump
them or knock them or they just get
unhappy or they get too hot or they get
too cold they are temperamental little
buggers so we went well what if what if
we could have memory that um didn't lose
all its contents when you disconnected
the power
and this is impossible according to the
rules of classical physics you cannot do
that but then quantum physics comes
along and goes hang on we got an idea we
have Quantum tunneling Quantum tunneling
is a way of electrons ending up being in
a place where they weren't supposed to
be and once they get there they get
stuck and this is how uh solid state
drives work this is how thumb drives
work this is how SD cards work they have
uh so every bit on your SSD hard drive
is a Quantum gate semiconductor which
uses quantum physics and exploits the
fact that the behavior of electrons
under certain high energy conditions is
non-deterministic and they can end up in
places where there wasn't actually a
circuit between where they started and
where they ended up I've sometimes
described this as like if you give your
children too much sugar and then put
them in the kitchen they can get from
the kitchen to the living room without
opening the door that's how Quantum
tunneling works for hard drives and
storage is fantastic for CPUs it is a
problem we've got down to a point where
we can manufacture CPUs where the
distance between these tracks is a 10
nanometers is common now seven
nanometers five nanometers is kind of
prototype and as Richard said this
morning somebody out there has got a one
nanometer transistor but at that point
the wires are so small and so close
together that the electrons will tunnel
from one wire to the next one and that
means that something that should have
been a one comes out as a zero the CPU
is no longer deterministic it's
unreliable you get wrong results it
crashes all kinds of stuff happens we
can't make them go any faster we can run
more of them in parallel which is where
an awful lot of the uh the kind of
efforts and investment around parallel
processing and asynchronous processing
are coming from but classical CPUs I'm
going to say this now and I know there's
folks recording this for YouTube so uh
you can come back and tell me I'm wrong
we are never going to see a retail CPU
clocked at more than five gigahertz it's
just not gonna happen because that is
the sort of upper limit of how fast
these things can go before the physics
breaks down and stops working but
maybe we don't need to use classical
CPUs
we talked about bits one zero true false
a classical computer everything is a one
or a zero that's how it all works all
the stuff we do with apps and unicode
and MP3 files really kind of boils down
to ones and zeros quantum computers are
like well
I don't want to decide I don't want to
make my mind up yet how about we pretend
it's a one and a zero at the same time
and then when we know what the answer is
we'll go and fill the answers back in
um somebody once described Quantum
algorithms to me as imagine flipping a
coin and then while it's in the air you
can stick another coin to it while it's
still spinning and you don't know which
one's which but you do know that you can
stick it so that if that one comes down
heads the other one will come down tails
it couples two qubits while you still
don't know their state such that the
state of one of them will influence the
outcome of the other and uh based on
this they've gone well if we could do
that we could do this algorithm and if
we do that algorithm then we can Factor
RSA and we can break public key
encryption we can do all these
astonishing things and uh so Quantum is
potentially a game changer now you can
go out there right now you can put your
MasterCard in Amazon and you can run
Amazon bracket and they will give you
space on a real quantum computer
um the Microsoft have one I know that
there's Q sharp they've got actual
Quantum in the cloud so if you are doing
things like you know nuclear reaction
simulation chemical simulation you can
go and you can buy time on Quantum
devices right now to run those
algorithms for most of the rest of us
you know
we're not really interested in Quantum
not yet it's interesting it's exciting
it's probably not going to be relevant
to the stuff we want to do with
computers because most of us aren't
simulating nuclear reactions or doing
protein folding looking for new chemical
compounds we listen to music again we
you know take photographs and we watch
movies and we check our bank balances
and all this kind of stuff and for the
time being classical Computing is
probably going to do a pretty good job
on all these kinds of things but
let's backtrack a bit I said a moment
ago a classical computer can represent
the values one and zero now one and zero
is an abstraction the ones and zeros
don't actually exist when I was a kid
this was my favorite show Star Trek next
Generation BBC Two every Wednesday night
six o'clock and uh the house where I
lived was kind of on a hill and the
transmitter was on the other side of the
Hill which meant we didn't get great
reception we didn't get a very good
signal and so when the weather was bad
I'd get home from school and tune in
Star Trek and you know if it was very
rainy or it was windy the picture would
kind of end up like this
now every single piece of that
transmission process was analog there
were no ones and zeros there is a
continuous wave like this of electricity
being fed into a TV transmitter that
puts out a continuous wave of radio that
hits the antenna on the top of my house
that goes through a bunch of transistors
and circuits and filters and diodes and
ends up scanning an electron beam across
the screen so if you start messing with
it the mess is very very smooth it's
very continuous you get a sort of
gradual degradation and a little bits of
Statics probing in and out
now
if any who has a demo light switches in
your house
these things used to work brilliantly
because all light bulbs were
incandescent
Light Bulb Has a Little tungsten
filament in it if you put a little bit
of electricity in it it gets a little
bit hot and you get a little bit of
light if you turn up the electricity you
get a little bit more heat you get a
little bit more light you turn it up all
the way it gets very hot it gets very
bright
how many out there have tried a low
energy LED bulbs with a dimmer switch
because some of them work right but some
of them they don't know whether they're
supposed to be on or off
because a light emitting diode is a
digital device it's either on or it's
off and so you turn the dimmer switch
and it's like definitely off
yeah kind of angry buzzing a little bit
you get in the middle maybe yeah and
then turn it all the way up and it's
like okay now I'm definitely supposed to
be on but that range in the middle a
solid state device like an LED it does
not know whether the wave you are
sending it is a one or a zero now that
example there that is the transition
from analog to digital circuits when
television in the UK switched from
analog to digital Broadcasting what
happened is when you couldn't get a
clear signal on Star Trek anymore you
wouldn't get kind of like wavy lines and
static you get jpeg noise
because every single one of the pistols
on your flat screen TV is being
controlled by a circuit that's like all
right a one or a zero well actually it's
eight bit color so we have eight ones or
zeros on the red channel eight ones or
zeros on the blue channel eight ones or
zeros on the green Channel we have a
whole bunch of processors and solid
state devices and you know chips and all
these things and because they are all
digital every single frame every single
Pixel times three colors times eight
bits per channel is a component trying
to decide whether the thing that just
came through the rain out of the sky
should be a one or a zero and when they
get it right
you get Star Trek and when they get it
wrong you get Star Trek jpeg compression
Edition that you downloaded on your
dial-up modem now
we live in a world of Unicode and apis
and net and cloud and Lambda and these
wonderful abstractions and you know it
is tempting to think well uh let's start
digging you know we chip away the layers
of abstraction we get down to ones and
zeros I'm like this is it this is the
bare metal ones and zeros you talk to
people who designed circuits you talk to
people who design chips they're like no
no ones and zeros it's just a luxury
abstraction actually the whole thing
that's going on is waves it's all about
waves it's all about fields and it's all
about trying to figure out whether a
particular electrical field at a certain
point in time should be interpreted as a
one or a zero and the code that we build
we have unit tests we have integration
tests we have continuous delivery and
then boom it all falls over and crashes
and we think oh well uh it's clearly not
a problem it works on my machine must be
the hosting environment now there was a
perception for a long long time that uh
even perfect software systems were going
to crash because of cosmic radiation
coming out of outer space and zapping
one of the bits in your memory bank and
that was going to crash your program and
you know this was sort of accepted
wisdom certainly When I Was An
undergraduate 2015 team at the
University of Toronto did the first
really large scale study into the
relationship between memory errors and
system stability and what they did they
got a bunch of Crash data and memory
usage data from some of the big super
Computing centers in the US and from
companies including Google and they
basically analyzed
the crashes and then they went and
studied the memory chips and the systems
which had exhibited crashes and what
they found out is one in ten of the
systems in their study had had a serious
fault related to memory one in 25 of
them that had actually crashed the
system unrecoverably and needed a hard
reboot
but when they then went and looked at
the memory banks they discovered that
those Banks were now prone to having
more errors in exactly the same place or
in adjacent locations the same Row the
same address column now what do you
think the odds are that a cosmic
radiation particle from outer space is
going to zap one of these things
and then six months later it's going to
go oh they've removed that ship to the
University of Toronto and it go over
there I'm going to zap it again
it's not Cosmic radiation it's
manufacturing faults dram doesn't work
it's not 100 reliable now
the problem with dram is you can't fix
it the manufacturing processes they spit
out a 16 gig ram chip and it either
works or it doesn't
and if it doesn't work you're like oh
well that one doesn't work throw it away
what semiconductor companies are trying
to do to increase the yield on their
manufacturing processes is they will
manufacture a 16 gig ram chip that's
actually got like 16.1 gigs of actual
space on it and then if they find a
problem during the quality control stage
they can patch that memory chip that
symbol that dim or whatever they can be
like okay that bank is bad so reroute
that bank to the spare one that we wired
and over here cut that one off don't use
it anymore this works at the factory
stage once the ram is then goes out into
Productions in your laptop it's in your
phone it's in a data center somewhere
there's not a whole lot they can do
about it now there's a technique that is
being trial it's been being trialed for
a long while
um which is called Dynamic page
retirement Nvidia is working on this on
some of their high-end gpus at the
moment and it's basically memory chips
that kind of carry a spare tire if they
detect that one of the pages on that
memory chip is no longer reliable they
will retire it and they will swap in
another one
some of the strategies for the sun
Microsystems had one back in 2004 an
experimental system where it didn't swap
in another one the ram just got a little
bit smaller and a little bit smaller and
a little bit smaller but this is based
on the observation that most people
would rather lose a couple of bytes of
memory than have an unreliable chip
running the system that their software
is running on now
you know some
we are talking about um Mission critical
we're talking about important data
centers where you have redundancy you
have all these kinds of things we've
seen that dram is not going to be 100
reliable there's nothing much you can do
about it and even shielding it from
outer space radiation is not necessarily
going to work and still once in a while
you are going to have there we go I like
the way my clicker failed at that exact
moment
so for the rest of us folks out here
building software for the real world we
can't really do anything about the ram
all we can do is we can anticipate the
user experience of what is going to
happen when something doesn't work we
can think that well how can we preserve
the user's experience how can we make
sure we still have their data if they're
in the middle of something how can we
make sure that next time they sign in or
they reboot or they refresh the page we
pick up when they left off and they
don't have to fill the whole thing in
again and this is a bad contingency
planning I've spent a large chunk of uh
last year or the last couple of years
doing remote talks and remote workshops
from home and I have backups for most
things if my internet drops I have a 4G
sim card in my ADSL router so I can fail
over to Cellular networking if my uh
power to my house was to go out
I can run about four hours of stuff off
my laptop battery Tethered to my phone
running off one of these battery packs
now if we get to a point as kind of
looked worryingly plausible for a little
while there and maybe still does where
uh they start switching off the
electricity to large parts of London
because they can't afford to run the
generators anymore I suspect we'd see a
lot of people going out and buying these
ups uninterruptible power supplies
basically a massive lead acid battery
that will run a couple of servers and
things for a while but worst case
scenario you know if the power to my
house goes out for an extended period of
time
it's going to sit in the dark you know I
sit and drink beer and light a candle
and read a book and stuff I grew up in
Zimbabwe where we had uh probably two or
three days a month the power would go
out for an extended period like several
hours at a time and we lived with it you
know we knew where the candles were we
knew where the flashlights were and we
knew how to beat my mother at Candle at
games of Monopoly until the lights came
back on this was inconvenient but it was
not a life or death situation now there
are applications where electricity is a
life or death situation there are
hospitals there are data centers there
are military command facilities
Emergency Services places where they
absolutely cannot afford to run on
Candlelight and papers until the power
comes back on have you ever
notice Red Power sockets in hospital
the red ones are the ones that stay on
the red Power sockets are the ones that
are fed by the diesel generator that is
in the basement so worst case scenario
the power goes out anything plugged into
a red socket by the way you cannot use
these to plug your laptop in to watch
YouTube they really don't like it when
you do that but most hospitals they have
generated facilities in the basement
they have battery backup the batteries
will keep them running until they can
get the generators up and the generators
will keep all of those critical life
support systems running for as long as
they can get supplies of diesel So in
theory they are self-sufficient on a
scale of decades assuming fuel supplies
are still available but
right at the start of this talk I said
you know one of the biggest challenges
we have around electricity is storing it
now sustainable energy is a big deal it
really is and the tragedy of this there
is enough free energy the amount of
sunlight that falls on planet Earth in a
given day is enough for everything that
we need to do it's just the wrong kind
of power and it's in the wrong place the
Sahara Desert
gigawatts of free electricity coming out
of the sky that is absolutely no use at
all if you are delivering groceries in
Antwerp in the middle of the night in
Winter now there is a an argument
which says that uh
almost all the energy in the world
actually came out of the Sun in the
first place because uh we have the Sun
generates power directly we have
electric cars we have solar-powered cars
there's a couple of prototypes of those
been floating around the world
um so if you are fueling your recharging
your Tesla off the solar panels on your
roof well done you that's an incredibly
green and sustainable way to live just
don't think about the manufacturing cost
of the materials or
Sun comes out or light comes out of the
sun and it lands on a tree and the tree
absorbs it and photosynthesis turns that
into sugar and then a dinosaur comes
along and eats the tree and then the
dinosaur Falls over and dies
and then the dinosaur goes and it turns
into crude oil and then we come along a
couple of million years later we dig up
the crude oil we refine it we put it in
the car so technically all of us are
driving solar powered cars
but maybe there is a better way of using
it than putting it in a tree feeding the
tree to a dinosaur killing the dinosaur
waiting 65 million years and then
digging the dinosaur up and setting it
on fire
this is the desert sunlight solafon this
is in California it's the biggest solar
power station in the World open in 2015
it generates enough power for 160 000
homes
but
only when the sun is shining now do
people in California need a whole lot of
power in the sun shining it's warm it's
bright you don't really need heating you
don't need lighting laptops are kind of
cool and it's nice to have the internet
so uh last uh last year towards the end
of last year they installed this this is
the biggest battery in the world this is
a bank of about 20 000 Samsung lithium
ion battery cells 230 megawatts of power
storage this will keep California's 160
000 homes going for about four hours
so Sun Goes Down And if you needed to
you could run on battery until about
midnight after that there's no more
power the thing that makes this useful
is for picking up spikes in supply and
demand because one of the biggest
challenges that we have with electricity
infrastructure the National Grid Supply
is that the demand for it is not
constant
I'm going to go back to the 4th of July
1990.
the Italian 90 World Cup England are
playing Germany and the World Cup
semi-final it is full time it is extra
time it is one goal to all it goes to
penalties
Chris waddle steps up to take his
penalty and he misses and he knocks
England out of the World Cup and 26
million people go that bollocks and they
get up and they put the kettle on to
make a cup of tea or they open the
fridge to get a beer out and there is
about a 2.6 gigawatt spike in the
electrical demand of the United Kingdom
in the space of about two minutes
now we don't have that kind of
electricity just hanging around because
storing it is incredibly difficult this
thing is called a TV pickup and it is
one of the biggest problems of managing
any kind of grid infrastructure what
happens when something happens that
means a lot of people suddenly want a
lot of electricity all at the same time
you have a massive spike in demand now
one of the best ways we found of storing
electricity is we don't actually store
the electricity we use the sunlight to
evaporate water the water goes up the
hill it falls as rain flows back down
the hill and then we go and we put a
bloody Great Wall in the way
and store the water behind it this is
Kariba Dan it's on the boundary on the
border between Zimbabwe and Zambia and
Africa and this was built to provide
power to the copper mines in the
northern part of Zambia it's one of the
world's biggest hydroelectric power
stations but there are actually places
in the world right now where when they
have Surplus electricity from solar from
wind power from a hydroelectric what
they do with it is they use the power to
pump the water back up the hill
it's called pump storage Hydro so you
have a bunch of water you get a lot of
sunshine you're like right run the
motors pump the water back up the hill
and then if you need power in the middle
of the night you just open the dam the
water comes through you can generate
electricity on that basis now the total
amount of uh pumped storage Hydro that
exists in the world is about 180
gigawatt hours
that would run London for around about a
day and a half and that is by far the
biggest store of energy that exists in
any system anywhere so if we had to run
the whole planet on batteries on the
stuff we've got backed up our laptops
would probably get us through to the end
of the day and then all the pump storage
Hydra on the planet could keep London
going until the end of the party
tomorrow night and then it would be game
over there is no more electricity
storage is not going to cut it we need
ways of generating electricity
sustainably and on demand now a little
while ago I was down here this is
Dungeness so on the south coast it is a
it's the only desert in the British
Isles and it is a weird place and uh
there are three things that you notice
as you approach Dungeness one as you
drive down towards it there are all you
cycle down towards it as I did on this
day you see these huge pylons carrying
high voltage power lines now we've got
good at building these things there are
power lines in China now which are
carrying millions of volts a couple of
thousand kilometers
the second thing you notice
is the wind turbines because this is a
big flat piece of land right out on the
edge of the country they have very very
steady prevailing winds it's fantastic
for kite surfing and kite buggy and a
lot of perps down there to do that and
then you get right to the end of
Dungeness and there's this
Dungeness nuclear power station
now uh other than the one that I
mentioned a second ago how many of you
can name a nuclear power station
which one is it Chernobyl Fukushima or
Three Mile Island
foreign
field yeah that one made the cut as well
the reason we know the names of these
power stations is because bad things
happen there which has massively
tarnished the reputation of nuclear
power in the public eye now there are
all sorts of things we can learn from
the circumstances surrounding what
happened you know if you've seen the HBO
miniseries you'll have seen a fairly
accurate dramatization of the corruption
and the mismanagement around the way
Chernobyl power station was being run
um Three Mile Island similar thing it
was people cutting corners on safety
checks and uh Fukushima was an
earthquake and a tidal wave at the same
time and it didn't actually melt down it
just it stopped generating power and
they had to go in and clean it up but
that was you know the scale of the
natural disaster that hit it relative to
the severity of the impact there it's
actually an astonishing piece of
engineering but
the reason why stations like Dungeness
are built way down on the southern coast
far away from anywhere one it needs to
be near water because that's the best
way we've got at the moment if you'll
know more about that go to Richard
Campbell's talk on Friday or he's
talking about a thing called a molten
salt nuclear reactor which is just
awesome but at the moment they tend to
need to be near water and people don't
want them in their backyard they want
electricity they want it now they want
it cheap but they do not want nuclear
power anywhere near where they live
because they are afraid of it so we put
it out in the middle of nowhere and the
only way we've got of getting it from
the place we generate it to the place
where we need it is to build these big
ugly monstrous expensive pylons and so
every once in a while the question comes
up
could we do wireless transmission like
could we have the nuclear power over
there and we're over here and we just
kind of beam the power from there to
there now we can do wireless power
transmission
about that far
we can do wireless charging of phones
and we can do wireless charging of
electric toothbrushes and you know we've
got pretty good at these kinds of things
but we're talking about you know maybe
tens of watts of power over a distance
of a few centimeters what we would
really like to be able to do is to
transmit electricity wirelessly over
larger distances now there's another
NASA thing called the power beam
challenge which is literally this you
have a robot they have a cable hangs off
a helicopter Cable's about a kilometer
long and you have a robot that claims
the cable using power beamed from the
ground
and the winning team the last time they
ran this in 2019
um this robot in the picture climbed 400
meters up that cable using tight Focus
microwave radiation being beamed up from
a base station and they want a bunch of
money from that and they started a
company called a powerbeam limited who
are now out there trying to do things
with uh you know Wireless transmission
of electricity but this is still a very
very Niche very specialist application
now we can transmit electricity through
empty air because if you crank the power
up high enough what happens is that you
start stripping the ions off the
molecules in air and air becomes
conductive and when that happens you get
a spark this is the spark you get when
you push the button to light your gas
cooker this is the crackle you get when
you plug something in to badly earthed
electrical equipment this
is how Tesla coil works
now Tesla coils are really really cool
because they are things that literally
make lightning they are incredibly
fragile they are incredibly expensive
they use a lot of electricity and the
biggest one in the world is in a private
collection in New Zealand this is a
picture of it it can send electricity
through the air a distance of around
about two meters maximum that's the best
we've got which is absolutely nothing
compared to what nature does every time
it gets a little bit weathery bolt of
lightning can carry 30 million volts of
electricity across a range of literally
miles now
uh well I was kind of putting this talk
together to deliver this week I stumbled
across a paper which I just thought was
awesome and it's early days and it
remains to be seen whether anything
comes out of this but there's a team in
Switzerland just published a paper about
using a high energy ionizing laser to
direct lightning bolts away from Radio
masts literally they shine a laser up
into the sky that is powerful enough
that it ionizes a column of air and
they've got a photograph which I do not
unfortunately have in the deck of a bolt
of lightning going oh yeah I'm going to
go down there that looks easier so who
knows maybe this could turn out to be
something maybe not this literally paper
was published on Monday but
but loved this idea you know a bolt of
lightning is absolutely awe-inspiring
and there is this wonderful quote about
information systems and processes which
Daisy owl tweeted a few years ago which
has stuck with me which is if you ever
code something that feels like a hack
but it works remember a CPU is literally
a rock that we tricked into thinking not
to over Simple Man first you have to
flatten the Rock and put lightning
inside it and so all of these systems
that all of us work with the mobile
phones in our pockets laptops desktops
Cloud networking all of this is possible
because once upon a time somebody looked
up at the sky saw a bolt of lightning
and a little part of their brain went I
wonder if we could catch that and put it
in a rock
thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]